So Leute, da bin ich, übrigens, was wir gestern programmiert haben im Stream hat funktioniert,
ich habe jetzt die Kamera auf der Terrasse draußen hängen und ich konnte dort vom Handy
der Katze zugucken, wie sie auf der Terrasse rumgestellt ist, was auch funktioniert ist
Licht an und aus machen an der Kamera, also eigentlich funktioniert alles relativ gut.
Das Einzige, was nicht funktioniert, gescheit ist, add-on-downloads im Home Assistant, weil
die gerade irgendwelche Probleme mit GitHub haben, aber an sich hat sich das gelohnt und
es war gar nicht so kompliziert, also muss ich sagen, haben wir gestern relativ schnell
rausgekriegt alles.
Ja und Leute, ansonsten, was geht so, also bescheuerte Frage, nichts, oder?
Es ist 9 Uhr Sonntags, was soll so groß gehen?
Bett gehen geht bei den meisten wahrscheinlich, aber ich bin schon ein bisschen wach, ich
bin seit ungefähr einer Stunde wach, auch wenn es sich nicht so anhört, Vogel bin ich
seit einer Stunde.
Kappa, komm, das ist ein guter Name, aber point.
Lebt der Friseur noch?
Ja, der hat letztens aus, der Friseur hat einen neuen Job.
Der Friseur arbeitet nicht mehr als Friseur, der Friseur arbeitet jetzt in irgendeinem Tattoo-Studio
und da haben die sogar letztens gestreamt raus.
Moin, schon das neue IT-Video von Lohntee?
Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich heute Morgen empfohlen bekommen und habe das schon aufgemacht,
das gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Nach dem wöchentlichen Level Cap G-Bate natürlich.
Jetzt kam die Bot-Message, pock.
Wobei, Leute, ist es pock oder ist es pog oder ist es P-O-G oder P-O-G, das ist halt
die große Frage, weiß keiner so genau.
Pog, nee, das eher nicht, pock, geil.
Die Discord-Notification-Gang, da ist, dann hat es jetzt alles funktioniert, sieht man
auch gleich.
Es ist auf einen Schlag irgendwie 40 Leute dazugekommen, das ist immer so geil.
Twitch braucht immer so, ja, 30 Sekunden bis 10 Minuten, bis es überall angezeigt wird,
dass man online ist.
Welche Zeit haben wir eigentlich in den USA gerade?
CET, CET, 2, oh, wie heißt das, EST, EST, klingt glaube ich gut.
Machen wir irgendwie keine Ahnung.
3 Uhr Nachts haben wir beiden Amis, okay.
Hast du das Zampa-Video zur Windows Toolbox Shardware?
Ja, das ist das Wort, das spricht da immer gerne aus, Zampa-Video, nein, ich hab noch
nicht das Video zur Windows Toolbox Shardware gesehen.
Was, was ist das, okay, das gucken wir uns gleich mal an, okay, schauen wir mal, wer
weiß, was wir da vielleicht installiert haben.
Also, schauen wir mal, die Windows Toolbox ist Shard, Shardware, was ist denn die Windows
Toolbox?
Aber in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, jawoll.
Anzeige ist raus.
Die tiefer gehende Prüfung des Ganzen, die läuft derzeit noch, ich kann noch nicht abschließend
sagen, was, wann, wie genau passiert ist, aber auf jeden Fall die Warnung, die sollte
man so schnell wie möglich raushauen.
Und zwar geht es um das Programm hier, Windows Toolbox haben wir vor einigen Tagen vorgestellt,
das Video ist...
Habe ich nicht installiert?
Werde ich auch nicht installieren?
Nö, jetzt ist eigentlich Lautstärke, müsste eigentlich ziemlich okay sein.
Inzwischen natürlich wieder offline genommen worden.
Na ja, okay, vielleicht ein bisschen.
Und zwar geht es da um ein Programm, mit dem man seinen Windows 10, ich sag jetzt mal,
optimieren kann.
Also allein schon, wenn ich sowas sehe, dass man seinen Windows optimieren kann, da bin
ich raus, das kommt mir eh nicht auf den Rechner.
Funktionen, die in dem Video vorgestellt wurden, die werden auch grundsätzlich gemacht, also
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem Programm Cortana abgeschaltet hat, dann wurde das
auch gemacht.
Also so war es jetzt nicht ganz.
Aber der Punkt ist einfach, in dem Code hier, der ja da offenbar open source ist, da gibt
es einen Teil, und zwar diesen Teil hier.
Ah ja, obvius, alles klar.
Das sieht schon mal verdächtig aus, solche Dinger.
Der ist verschlüsselt und der hat Schadwehr in sich im weitesten Sinne.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Virus, der sich irgendwie weiter verbreitet, sondern solange
oder soweit das eben eine oberflächliche Geschichte, die wir jetzt da abgesucht haben,
ergeben hat, wird hier mit diesem Code unter anderem das eigentliche Programm, das hier
vorliegt, komplett ersetzt und nachgebaut.
Insoweit bin ich derzeit der Meinung, dass der Code hier von einem anderen stammt, der
eben...
Also im Prinzip tun die nur so, als wären sie die Microsoft Toolbox danach.
Okay, das ist weird champ.
Dieses Optimierungstool geschrieben hat und...
Wahrscheinlich hat das dann die Schiller-Chinesen verkauft oder so.
Irgendjemand hat diesen Originalcode genommen, hat sich selbst mit seiner Schadwehr hier verewigt
und hofft eben darauf, dass es kaum einer merkt und ja, wir haben es ja auch zum Beispiel
nicht gemerkt.
So, was das Programm, wie gesagt, oberflächliche Prüfung bisher, wir haben das gestern im Twitch-Stream
gemacht, wer da mal mit vorbeischauen will an genaueren Einzelheiten.
Hat das jemand von euch installiert?
Also ich kenne das nicht.
Ist, kann ja gerne mal vorbeischauen, da machen wir nämlich nachher noch weiter, weil ist
nicht ganz unaufwendig die Geschichte.
So, was ich bisher jedenfalls rausgefunden habe, ist, das Programm sucht sich die Installation
vom Google Chrome, von Microsoft Edge und vom Wave-Bowser und es scheint so zu sein,
als wenn...
Na gut, Firefox ist mittlerweile so unbedeutend, es juckt keinen mehr, na gut, es ist nicht
Chromebase.
Eine Webseite oder eine Datei auf dem Installationsverzeichnis leicht verändert wird und wenn man dann den
Chrome, ich weiß nicht, ob man den Chrome bei jedes Mal, wenn man ihn aufruft, im Grunde
wird dann aber Facebook aufgerufen.
Facebook?
Das ist der Teil, den ich bis jetzt gesehen habe und der mir dann auch gereicht hat, um
zu sagen, okay, hier ist definitiv was, nicht ganz kosher.
Facebook?
Who cares Facebook?
So, wie gesagt, das wird alles noch genauer über Poli-Studie-Antiviren-Hersteller, die
sind alle informiert und Virus-Total weiß auch Bescheid insoweit, da wird es eine entsprechende
Warnung geben.
Also, also wenn ich irgendwie Trojaner bei einem auf dem Rechner installiert hätte,
würde ich gar nicht Facebook aufmachen, aber okay.
Wenn man in den Virus-Programmen unterwegs ist, da wird es wahrscheinlich dann auch dem
nächsten Warnung geben.
Vielleicht ist das einfach nur ein Test, ob es funktioniert.
Wir müssen nur 24, 48 Stunden Zeit geben, bis die das Ganze eben auch nachsagen sollen
haben.
Ja, okay.
Die werden ja im Grunde dann...
Gut, ja, ist natürlich doof, wenn man es installiert hat, aber habe ich nicht installiert.
Habe ich nicht.
Aber Facebook, ne, verstehe ich auch nicht, lull.
Keine Ahnung, aber es ist schon witzig, dass sie Fat-Werbung machen.
Jetzt ist das doch mal an, wartet mal, ich mach das mal kurz auf.
Linux-VM muss gestartet werden, damit wir uns das angucken können.
Ich guck da mal kurz auf GitHub jetzt selbst rein.
Vorgabe aus VM muss gestartet werden, genau.
Ich kann auch mit der Qt-VM mal wieder reingucken.
Ne, das stimmt, heute ist komplett falsch, lull.
Zeig mal her.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Windows-GitHub-Toolbox-Windows-Toolboxer Also nicht installieren Leute, ne, das da wahrscheinlich.
Das, ne.
Ja, das, das müsste es sein.
Ist auch geil.
Open Source, guck mal, Open Source, wunderbar, aber im GitHub-Repo ist kein Source-Code drin.
Das ist auch schon mal holst verdächtig, oder?
Ich mein, wozu gibt es denn ein GitHub-Repo, wenn da nichts zu drinnen ist?
Warum soll ich den Source-Code mir hier angucken, das ist doch bescheuert, oder?
Ja, guck mal, hehe.
Okay, das ist irgendeine PowerShell-Magic, tatsächlich.
Das ist, die haben doch einfach nur einen GitHub-Account, damit das vertrauenswürdiger
aussieht, oder?
Weil ansonsten hat der GitHub-Account doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Da war doch auch mal Source-Code drin, oder, guck mal, das hat doch nicht umsonst so viele
Sterne gekriegt.
Hier ist ja, hier ist ja nichts drinnen im Endeffekt.
Ja, wir gehen einfach mal, keine Ahnung, gehen wir mal irgendwie dahin.
Nee, da war noch nie, da war noch nie Source-Code drin, da war noch nie Source-Code drin.
Okay, dann, dann verstehe ich den Sinn davon, ehrlich gesagt.
Nicht wirklich, wenn da noch nie Source-Code drin war?
Was haben die denn sonst noch so für Tools auf ihrem GitHub-Account?
Nur das da, tja.
Das ist ja mal.
Überall wirst du gescampt, Leute.
Überall wirst du gescampt, ist ja schlimm.
Überall ist gar nix, deswegen eigentlich das einzige, was man machen kann, Brain-Exe einschalten.
Oder, gut, wir sind ja nicht alle unter Windows unterwegs, das Brain-Binary, gibt es eigentlich
ein Programm, was Brain heißt?
Nee.
JetBrains, es gibt kein Programm, was Brain heißt, das ist aber, es gibt wirklich keins.
Ich lehne das jetzt einfach, weil es gibt kein, das ist aber ziemlich, das ist Absicht,
oder?
Weil, das wundert mich jetzt, es gibt eigentlich ziemlich alle Sachen einfache Wörter als
Commando-Zeilen-Tools.
Brain ist Legacy-Feature, ja, das stimmt.
Brain ist Overrated, Outdated, Chebated, da Gehirn braucht man nicht.
Ich sag mal ehrlich, wahrscheinlich ist es in der heutigen Zeit tatsächlich besser,
bei manchen bescheuerten Dingern, die passieren, dass sich abzuschalten, weil man sonst Schäden
davon trägt.
Aber man sollte das hier nie so weit abschalten, dass man das nicht wieder einschalten kann.
Wie kann Brain Access stoppen zu wirken, kann ich dir erzählen, als ich mal auf dem Sofa
in der alten Wohnung noch, habe ich mal auf dem Sofa gelegen und Fernsehen geguckt und
irgendwann habe ich festgestellt, ah Mist, ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Und da bin ich aufgesprungen vom Sofa und zum Klo gerannt und im Flur bin ich umgekippt.
Da hat Brain Access, nein, ich will das nicht aufmachen, da hat Brain Access aufgehört
zu wirken.
Ich bin mitten im Flur umgekippt, ich bin wahrscheinlich einfach zu schnell aufgestanden
vom Sofa und zu schnell losgerannt, also ich bin komplett ohnmächtig geworden im Flur.
Es kann passieren, wenn man da irgendwie eine Stunde auf dem Sofa liegt und dann aufkriegt
und losflitzt zum Klo, wobei das war ein ganz merkwürdiges Erlebnis, weil ich kann mich
da jetzt, ich meine, man weiß ja nur noch, an was man sich kreislaufend rebootet, genau,
man kann sich da natürlich nur an die Sachen erinnern, an die man sich halt wirklich noch
erinnern kann und zwar, ich dachte dann irgendwie, als ich wieder zu mir gekommen bin, ne zum
Glück, zum Glück nicht, ich weiß plus noch, als ich da wieder zu mir gekommen bin, dachte
ich erst so, ich lieg aufm Sofa, weil sich das Hirn zusammen reimt zu den letzten Sachen,
die irgendwie plausibel klingen und dann hab ich irgendwann gemerkt, ne, du liegst nicht
im Sofa, du liegst in irgendeinem dunklen Raum, weil im Flur, das war halt abends, war
schon dunkel und irgendwann bin ich dann immer weiter zu mir gekommen und dann hab ich dann
als nächstes festgestellt, ah meine Schulter tut mir weh und dann bin ich halt aufgewacht
und hab festgestellt, ich lieg auf dem, das ist so, ich liege auf der Box, wo die Schuhe
drin sind, mit der Schulter, so ne Holzbox, bin ich da draufgefallen und deswegen hab
mir auch die Schulter wehgetan, ja, sehr einprägsames Erlebnis, ja also seitdem bin ich sonst nie
wieder ohnmächtig geworden, aber das war Kreislauf X, da hat sich verabschiedet, ja, echt, ja,
das sind halt alles noch Hacker-Mans in der Selbstfindungsphase, ja, da kann man schon
mal, da kann man schon mal eintragen, guckst du aktuelle, ne, ich guck nicht so wirklich
viel, generell, also ich muss sagen, mein Film und Serie, ich guck natürlich ab und
zu mal was, ja, so ist das nicht, aber mein Film und Serienkonsum ist im Vergleich zu
früher kaum noch, kaum noch vorhanden, ich guck ab und zu mal was, ja, aber ich gucke
tatsächlich zum größten Teil Twitch, Youtube oder guck was es neues auf Steam gibt oder
irgendwie sowas, also Fernseh guck ich gar nicht mehr, null, ansonsten ab und zu mal Film
oder Serie auf Amazon oder irgendwo anders, sich das besorgen, wo auch immer man sich
Serien und Filme so besorgen kann und dann wird das meistens am Stück geguckt und gut
ist, ja, Fernseh, Fernseh ist wirklich Monarch S, also ich hab mal, also wo ich klein war,
das weiß ich noch, da war ich mit meinem Vater in der Sauna und ich hab nix gefrühstückt,
da war ich, keine Ahnung, acht oder so, oder zehn oder so, da war ich noch klein, ich
hab nix gefrühstückt und morgens auch nicht wirklich Monarch S, dieses Emote hier, also
ich hab nix großartig gefrühstückt und ich hab noch nix getrunken und ich hab dann in
der Sauna mit meinem Vater und ich weiß noch, da sind ja immer so Holzbänke wo man da drauf
sitzt und ich saß relativ nah an der Tür, ich weiß nicht wie, ich war schon ewig nicht
mehr in der Sauna, wie warm ist es da drinnen, 60 Grad, 30 Grad, nee 30 Grad wahrscheinlich
oder 40 Grad, 50 Grad, ich, keine Ahnung, es war warm, ja, es war warm und naja, zumindest
guck ich halt auf den Boden und merke so, dass mein Sichtfeld, normalerweise ist ja,
dort wo du hinguckst, ist ja eigentlich gleichmäßig alles ausgeleuchtet, ja, also du siehst, du
siehst an, in der Mitte wo du dich drauf fokussierst und halt an den Augenrändern, also quasi
an dem, an dem, außen am Blickfeld, du siehst alles gleich hell, ja, du siehst das zwar
nicht gleich scharf, aber du siehst eigentlich alles gleich hell, so und dann hab ich gemerkt,
dass es von außen, von links und rechts außen so in das Sichtfeld rein dunkel wird, bis,
so wie so ein Vorhang den man zumacht, ganz komisch, als ich auf die Erde geguckt hab
und irgendwann, war nur noch, quasi, ganz kleines Stück was ich sehen konnte, hell und
in dem Moment ist mir klar geworden, Max, du bist kurz vorm Umkippen, du musst aus der
Sauna raus, bin ich aus der Sauna raus, hab mich draußen hingesetzt und wurde auch gleich
instant wieder besser, also, das war, ja, das weiß ich doch, das hat mich geschockt,
ich wusste bis zu dem Zeitpunkt damals gar nicht, dass so was geht, ja gut, aber das
war die Kombination aus Sauna, nix trinken und nix essen, Hof runtergeschraubt für
mehr FPS, so könnte man das auch sehen, ja, aber da ist es einem auch ziemlich schlecht
danach, das ist wirklich komisch, ja, das ist wirklich scheiße, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
Pepo Pupu, das ist wirklich kacke, Homer, Dankeschön für den Sub, 16 Monate, ne, das
ist wirklich heftig, also, das krasseste, was ich so die letzten Jahre über hatte,
war die Lebensmittelvergiftung vom Rahmenschnitzel, vom Liefer-Service, ich bin mir mittlerweile
ziemlich sicher, es kam nicht vom Döner-Teller, sondern es kam vom Rahmenschnitzel, das passt
zeitlich einfach viel besser, also ich habe einen Rahmenschnitzel bestellt beim Liefer-Service
und Rahmenschnitzel passt ja auch, gerade so diese Rahm-Soße, das ist ja quasi Milch
und Joghurt halte ich und so, so, und da hatte ich irgendeinen, frag mich nicht, bla bla bla,
Bakter, irgendein Darm-Virus oder was das war oder Bakterien oder keine Ahnung, zumindest,
das war richtig krass, du legst den Bett, keine Salmonellen, achso, in Überraschungseier
sind Salmonellen, habe ich gelesen, so, Kampylo-Bakter, ich glaube, das kann es gewesen sein, zumindest,
du legst den Bett, du legst den Bett und denkst dir kacke, du musst aufs Klo, das kommt öfters
vor, wenn du so, wenn du Lebensmittelvergiftung hast, so, und wenn du versuchst aufzustehen,
normalerweise ist das kein Ding, ja, normalerweise, wenn du im Bett legst, versuchst aufzustehen,
machst du halt zack, Beine hoch, zack, raus und springst auf, gar kein Problem, dauert
drei Sekunden oder so, dort musste ich, it's ungelogen, ich musste mich auf die Seite rollen,
das hat schon zehn Sekunden gedauert, dann musste ich die Beine runter machen, das hat
nochmal zwanzig Sekunden gedauert und dann musste ich mich wirklich ohne Scheiß mit
den, mit den Armen so vom Bett hochdrücken, dass das funktioniert hat, das hat nochmal
zwanzig Sekunden gedauert, so richtig, und als ich dann gestanden habe, habe ich gedacht,
mich zieht das direkt rückwärts ins Bett zurück, das habe ich so auch noch nie erlebt,
also ich habe, ich habe bestimmt zwei Minuten gebraucht alleine zum Aufstehen, wenn ich
aufs Klo musste, also das war wirklich heftig, und das war auch das einzige Mal, dass ich
je Post vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen habe, dass ich, dass ich irgendeinen Fragebogen
ausfüllen muss, weil das eine meldepflichtige Krankheit ist, ach ja und falls ich in der
Gastronomie arbeite, darf ich auf gar keinen Fall auf die Arbeit gehen, zum Glück arbeite
ich nicht in der Gastronomie, GPIOs 34-39 sind Input Only, das wusste ich nicht, aber
kann ich, kann schon sein, du kannst beim ESP aber relativ viel umstellen, aber ich
glaube Input Only kannst du nicht umstellen, doch danach bin ich aufs Klo, danach bin ich
aufs Klo, aber ich halte erst mal zwei, drei Minuten, die glaube ich auch aufgestanden
bin, jaja, na gut, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt heute an, Firefox Must Survive, ist das
der Typ, das ist der Typ, der eigentlich keinen Firefox mehr verwenden will, what the fuck,
haben wir uns nicht letztens ein Video von, haben wir uns nicht letzte Woche ein Video
von dem Dude angeguckt, wo er erzählt hat, I'm leaving Firefox, wo er dann gesagt hat,
er tauscht Firefox gegen den Gnome Browser aus und fand, und fand er dann Gnome, der
wollte kein Edge benutzen, kein Chrome, ja genau, er hat gesagt, er hat keinen Bock mehr
auf Firefox und deswegen Chrome, aber Chrome will er auch nicht und dann hat er gesagt,
er benutzt den Gnome Browser und da haben wir im Video schon gesagt, so ein Schwachsinn,
der Gnome Browser, da taugt doch nix und danach hat er ein Video gemacht, ja Gnome Browser
taugt nix und jetzt ist er auf einmal wieder Firefox Must Survive, so, so, oh man, fakeapple.com,
das haben wir schon offen, das gucken wir uns gleich an, wenn der Verfassungsschutz
anruft, das ist ein guter Titel, der Verfassungsschutz hat ja gar nicht bei ihm angerufen, wenn ich
seine, also ich hab das Video nicht geguckt, aber wenn ich seinem Twitter, Twitter-Post
glaube, geht das in diesem Video darum, dass es eine Betrugsmasche gibt, das angeblich
der Verfassungsschutz anruft, aber das ist ein guter Titel oder ein gutes Thumbnailer,
denkt jeder, bei ihm hat der Verfassungsschutz, Verfassungsschutz angeruft, oh, can you stalk
someone with an, ja kann man, dachte ich zumindest, deswegen machen sie auch gerade alle Panik,
es gibt ja sogar schon Leute, die sagen, Apple muss die AirTags wieder vom Markt nehmen,
wo ich mir auch denke, Apple ist doch nicht dafür verantwortlich, dass die Leute ihr
Produkt für illegale Aktivitäten nutzen, du kannst fast alles für illegale Aktivitäten
benutzen, was es gibt, das heißt ja aber nicht, dass man das unbedingt vom Markt nehmen sollte,
ich weiß nicht, ob den Leuten klar ist, man kann sogar Küchenmesser für illegale Aktivitäten
benutzen, ja, man kann fast alles für illegale Aktivitäten benutzen, aber da kann ja der
Hersteller in den selbsten Fällen was für, es sei denn, er begünstigt das halt irgendwie
extrem, das ist quasi, wie soll ich sagen, wie zum Beispiel VPN-Anbieter, die dafür
werben, dass man mit ihnen illegale Sachen machen kann oder so, ja, das ist dann natürlich
wieder was anderes, aber du kannst, wenn du es drauf anlegst, fast alles für illegale
Sachen verwenden, deswegen muss man das trotzdem nicht vom Markt nehmen.
Ja, ne, das haben wir noch nicht angeschaut, das gucken wir uns an, was ich gut finde ist,
dass man eigenes Video mir empfohlen wird, ich muss das mal kurz öffnen, einfach für
die View-Time, ja, und mal kurz gucken, ob es neue Comments gibt, aha, ok, ok, alles
klar.
Sehr schön, gut, jetzt haben wir, ich lasse die View-Time mal view-timen für mich, na,
ist ja nicht verboten, seine eigenen Videos zu gucken, Sack, Hydrated Stain, ja, die habe
ich alle gesehen, die meisten fand ich nicht lustig davon, ein paar sind cool, also die
mit dem JavaScript-Entwickler war lustig, aber ein paar andere Sachen, die ich gesehen
habe, waren nicht so, nicht so Lull, Keg W, tja, dann gucken wir mal, also was gucken wir
uns an, nein, wir gucken sich mal ein eigenes Video an, das Gehalt als IT-System-Administrator,
Leute, mit was wollen wir anfangen, wollen wir uns Level Cap, traditionell Level Cap chibaten
lassen oder wollen wir uns als erstes angucken, das Gehalt als IT-System-Administrator?
Wir fangen einfach mit Level Cap an, wir fangen immer mit Level Cap an und danach gucken wir
uns den IT-System-Administrator an, Admin, please, Admin, please, sag mal, weißt du,
warum Twitch ihre App abschalten, machen sie, wie Twitch schaltet ihre App ab, wie
sollen wir dann auf dem iPhone gescheit gucken, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, wie kommst
du da drauf, wie kommst du, hast du mal einen Link, Twitch-App, nicht, nicht, au, App, News,
ach, die Desktop-App, ja gut, das kann ich dir sagen, weil die Desktop-App wahrscheinlich
keine Sau verwendet, hat irgendjemand mal, seriously von euch, hat irgendjemand die Desktop-App
jemals verwendet von Twitch, ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht, dass es die gibt, ich meine,
wozu, ich meine, im Browser, gerade mit den ganzen Addons von FFZ, BitBetter, TwitchTV
oder wie heißt das neue, 7, irgendetwas, warum sollte ich, warum, warum genau sollte ich
denn eine Twitch-Desktop-App verwenden, läuft die unter Arch, by the way, das ist eine gute
Frage, wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich Windows-UWP-Only, 500 MB, dann ist es bestimmt
einfach eine Elektron-App, ja also, das kann ich verstehen, die verwendet ja keiner, dein
Dozent nutzt die, ja gut, es gibt Leute, die sind weirdchamp, der verwendet wahrscheinlich
auch Auferhead-Projektoren und sowas, also, wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, wollt
ihr doch, dass wir das, das, das Admin-Video zuerst gucken, oder, ok, dann gucken wir das
Admin-Video zuerst, so, mein eigenes Video lasse ich laufen, die View-Time muss sein,
also Server, Telefon und Netzwerke, das Gehalt als IT-System-Administrator, lohnt sich das,
die Frage kann man eigentlich pauschal immer beantworten bei diesen Videos, relativ einfach,
es kommt drauf an, auf die Region, auf den Arbeitgeber und überhaupt, ob sich das lohnt,
ist, glaube ich, bei kaum einem Beruf pauschal mit Ja oder Nein zu beantworten, na gut, ja,
ich bringe mein Geld schon gut unter die Leute, ich atme ein, ich raste ja außen, was, what,
er bringt sein Geld unter die Leute, ok, jetzt, auf geht's, ich bringe mein Geld schon gut
unter die Leute, richtige Ecker, man, ich atme ein, ich raste ja außen, jetzt geht die natürlich
wieder nicht rein, wir haben halt ein Geldindustrie, jawoll, alles steht und fällt mit der IT, die
gute blaue 18 Volt Bosch Schlagbohr, ich bin 22 Jahre alt und IT-System-Administrator in
Arschheim bei München, das ist noch, das ist noch richtiger Turnschuh-Admin, wie man das
früher so genannt hat, da werden auch mal Löcher in die Wand gebohrt, ich bin immer fit, ah guck
mal hier ein guter Dymolabel-Drucker, die Dinger, da muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ranten
drüber, der Hersteller hat komplett den Arsch offen, wisst ihr auch warum, wahrscheinlich
nicht, deswegen sag ich's euch, die haben DRM in ihre Papierrollen eingebaut, ist jetzt
kein Witz, die neuen Dymodrucker möchten ein RFID-Label in ihren Papierrollen haben,
das heißt, wenn du dir Papierrollen holst, von einem anderen Hersteller, ohne das offizielle
Dymo RFID-Label, dann funktionieren die in deinem Drucker nicht mehr, das ist komplett
für'n Arsch, hier, lest euch das mal durch, Etikettendrucker erzwingt DRM Papierrolle,
das muss man sich mal vorstellen, es ist Papier, es gibt keinen Grund, dass das DRM gesichert
ist, kann man das RFID-Label von der alten Rolle nehmen, ich wette mit ihr, die haben
da irgendwelche Tricks eingebaut, es ist absolut lächerlich, meine Güte, egal, so,
wollte ich jetzt bloß mal loswerden, weil ich hier so'n Dymo gesehen hab, gibt's auch
genug Alternativen, ich hab auch so'n Ding, ich hab mir so'n Ding erst letztens gekauft,
weil ich vom PC Labels drucken will, ich hab ja die ganze Zeit so'n Handgerät gehabt,
wo man eintippen musste, tja, okay, egal, wir gucken jetzt das Video.
Erst früh ist mir so'n 8.30 Uhr das Arbeiten an, also, ausgeschlafen ist man meistens so
zu mindestens 90%, und für uns ist immer lustig, also jeden Tag geht man gerne in die
Arbeit.
Voll, richtig schön fetten 128 Zoll Curved, oder was das ist, das Ding ist ja ein riesen
Monitor, Alter, richtig massive, also das ist wirklich ein 6 Head Monitor.
Und noch neben einen Hochkant, auf die Idee bin ich ja noch gar nicht gekommen, ich hab
hier einfach nur zwei ganz normale 24 Zoll Bildschirme nebeneinander.
Das ist ja ziemlich outdated, wenn ich das Setup so sehe.
Guckt euch mal das Desktop Hintergrundbild hier an, da fehlt ein bisschen was.
Mittelständische Kunden, und wir sind bei denen eigentlich zuständig, von da, vom kleinen
Router bis über den großen Surfer, über die Netzwerkverkabelung, über die Infrastruktur,
über Computer, wir machen eigentlich von A bis Z alles, was irgendwie an ein Netzwerk
angeschlossen werden kann.
Ich hole jetzt Werkzeug, Bohrmaschine, Akkuschrauber und das ganze, was man halt dafür braucht,
und wir bauen bei einem Kunden eine neue Telefonanlage ab.
Das ist noch richtig klassischer Turnschuh-Admin, so ein bisschen das, was ich früher, als ich
noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab, auch gemacht hab, im Vergleich zu heute, wo ich noch nicht
mal weiß, wie ich genau ins Rechenzentrum reinkomme, war ich damals jeden Tag mehrfach
da.
Das ist wirklich komplett unterschiedlich, also wenn ich quasi den Job jetzt mit dem
Job vor 10 Jahren vergleiche, ist es wirklich ein riesen Unterschied.
Also gut, ich bin ja auch nicht mal da, wo ich damals gewesen bin, aber da hat sich schon
einiges geändert.
Ein, der kriegt 5 Funktelefone und zwei so Deckverstärker, wo sich die Telefone einwählen.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken, ob wir alles haben, das ist die Duplex.
Die, das sind die guten alten Wagen, die man nur vorne rum lenken kann.
Davon hat eigentlich so gut wie jeder, jedes Lager hat solche Wagen, die haben mich oftmals
zur Verzweiflung gebracht, ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt, wie man diese Wagen ordentlich
fährt.
Die Wagen sind nämlich nicht zum, die Wagen sind nämlich nur zum Ziehen gedacht, nicht
zum Schieben.
Das heißt, wenn du die Wagen ziehst, kannst du die gut lenken, weil hier hinten, nur
die Räder hinten können lenken, die Räder vorne sind starr.
Das heißt, manchmal musst du den Wagen aber schieben und das kriegst du nicht hin, weil
die, du kannst sie nicht lenken, weil die Räder vorne starr sind.
Was du machen kannst ist, kurz anheben ein Stück und, da gibt es lustige Geschichte,
du kannst diese Wagen kurz anheben und umsetzen, dass du um die Ecke kommst, wenn du beispielsweise
aus dem Fahrstuhl rausfahren musst und nicht gut eingeparkt hast.
Und wir haben mal Loadbalancer Server rübergefahren ins Rechenzentrum, wie gesagt, als ich noch
beim Provider gearbeitet habe und so ein Loadbalancer kostet ungefähr 40.000, die 40.000 Euro
das Stück.
Also sprich, das Zeug ist wirklich, wirklich teuer gewesen, waren so entweder ein HE oder
zwei HE-Kisten, gab beides und die haben wir voll geladen bis hier oben, wir wollten nicht
zu zweit, sind wir rüber gelaufen, die haben wir voll geladen bis hier oben auf dem Wagen.
Die Sache ist halt die, diese Wagen haben keinerlei Schutz nach links und rechts und wer schon
mal Server auf Server gelegt hat, weiß, die Dinger rutschen, je nach Beschichtung, aber
die meisten rutschen.
Das heißt, einer musste auf die Seite gehen, in die der Bürgersteig abschüssig war und
die 5-6 Server festhalten und der andere hat gezogen.
So, und dann kam Hardwarebalancer, ja, gibt es, gibt es immer noch, ist sogar immer noch
relativ verbreitet, Hardwareloadbalancer, oder zumindest so Appliance-Kisten, aber damals
waren das wirklich richtig echte Hardware, die wurden auch so geliefert vom Hersteller.
So, und jetzt, jetzt kommst du, da musste man über die Ampel und ich wollte das schieben
über die Ampel, nicht ziehen, und dann wollte ich das Ding umsetzen, es war ein riesen,
also nach vorne, das war ein riesen Act, das Ding umzusetzen, weil es war voll geladen
mit Servern und dann kam das Problem, ich hab das Ding, du kannst hinten den Fuß drauf
machen hier, also das hier ist, dass es runterklappt, du kannst aber hinten ein bisschen den Fuß
drauf machen und dich drauf stellen, so, dann hab ich das Ding angehoben und dann ist der
oberste, so eine 1HE-Kiste, ist gerutscht hierdurch, und das ist mir dann halt, es ist, es ist
nicht runtergefallen, es ist nicht runtergefallen, es ist mir gegen's Bein gerutscht, ja, aber
das war wirklich, das war wirklich knapp, 20.000 Euro sonst hinüber, kann schon mal
passieren, aber, also, man darf, man darf das aber nicht unterschätzen, das ist manchmal
gar nicht so ungefährlich, vor allem, weil die Leute leichtsinnig werden mit der Zeit,
ich gehe davon aus, dass er auch keine Sicherheitsschuhe an hat oder so, und ich hatte auch nie Sicherheitsschuhe
an beim Server einbauen oder sonstige Geschichten, aber, ein Kollege von mir, damals, wie gesagt,
auch beim Provider, dem ist mal ein Dell 380, Dell DL 380, oder HP, nee HP ist das, HP
ist das, nicht Dell, HP, 2HE, so eine Kiste, aber noch die alten, die grau waren, so in
der Richtung, ist dem beim Einbauen mit der Kante auf den Fuß gefallen, der war zwei Wochen
oder so im Krankenhaus, oder was heißt im Krankenhaus, im Krankenhaus und dann zwei Wochen krank
und hat, monatelang konnte der nicht richtig laufen, hat einen dicken Fuß und hat verbannt
und alles drauf gehabt, also wenn dir so ein Ding aus, sagen wir mal, keine Ahnung, eineinhalb
Meter mit der Kante auf den Fuß fällt, da macht dein normaler Schuh nix dagegen, und
das ist dem halt wohl auf den großen Zeh gefallen und halt durch den Schuh durch und
das war ziemlich, ziemlich broken IF, ja, seht ihr mal, sogar, sogar das ist gefährlich.
Das ist die Einzeldose, schauen wir mal, wie lange wir effektiv brauchen, ich hoffe mal
nicht länger als drei Stunden, das war jetzt auch schon der Mann, der mein Gehalt bezahlt,
haben wir sowas in der Größe noch nicht so dreckig, ich hab nix anderes gefunden, vielleicht
am Aldo noch ne Dose an der Wandschraube, dann ist das zu lang, da muss ich den ganzen
Teil da mitnehmen, da müssten zwei Netzwerkkabel rein in der Werkstatt, das kann viel passieren
bei Telefonanlagen, es ist ab und zu anstrengend, da wirklich Durchblick zu behalten, weil das
verändert sich ja, auh, Iztrakeru, das klingt unangenehm, der Chef wirkt auch noch nicht
aufgewacht, der Chef ist wahrscheinlich auch seit 5.45 da und ist deswegen müde, vor allem,
wisst ihr, das würde mich ja schon mal mega aufregen, ich hab den Auftrag dort irgendwie
Netzwerkdosen einzubauen und eine Telefonanlage und der Chef ist so Kleinteilmanager mäßig
unterwegs, dass der mir noch erklären will, was ich gefälligst für eine Netzwerkdose
nehmen soll, boah, ich glaube, das wird mir echt mega auf den Sack gehen, ich glaube,
das wird mich wirklich richtig nerven, wenn ich bei jedem Handgriff, bei jeder Leiste,
bei jeder Netzwerkdose, die ich nehme, den Chef, der mir stehen hätte, der mir erklärt
so nach dem Motto, warum nimmst du nicht eine andere Dose?
Das ist jetzt so gebaut. Ah, ok. Da kannst du es hier ausbrechen, guck, da ist im Prinzip
so ne treue Seitenschneider im Auto. Stimmt, die guten Knicks, Seif Schneider. Ich fahre
mit meinem Auto zu Kundenterminen, ich hab keinen direkten Firmenwagen, ich rechne deshalb
mit der Firma ab, dass sich die Abnutzung und die Kosten einfach für diese Kundenfahrten
auf Null ausgehen. Mein Auto kostet mich knapp über 500 Euro im Monat, aber ich wohne auf
dem Land, das Auto ist total wichtig für mich. Waren kannst du dich nicht drauf verlassen.
Ich bin auf dem Auto Verrückter und das Auto hat 300 PS. Das ist wichtig. Das ist einfach
irgendwie... Aber mal wisst ihr was, mal ganz im Ernst, wenn man wirklich den Großteil
seines, ja, Alltags im Auto verbringt oder das Arbeitkurs Großteil der Zeitrenne verbringt,
dann darf es auch ein gescheites Auto sein. Ich erwarte nicht, dass die ganze Welt mit
dem Opel Agila rumfährt. Und wenn ich wirklich jeden Tag stundenlang rumfahren müsste mit
dem Auto, hätte ich auch ein ordentliches Auto und nicht das, was ich jetzt habe. Deswegen
kann ich schon verstehen. Da gibt es jetzt bestimmt wieder Leute, die sich dann drüber
aufregen und sagen, das muss doch nicht sein. Es ist immer ein Unterschied zwischen, was
wirklich Minimum sein muss und dem, womit man sich wohlfühlt. Und wenn man so viel Zeit
hat, kann man sich schon vorstellen, dass es praktisch ist oder angenehmer ist, ein
ordentliches Auto zu haben. Marc LDM, danke schön für den Zapp. Kleiner Luxus, den ich
nicht mehr gönne. Ja, mit der Bahn kannst du ja vergessen. Ich habe gesagt, mit 30
will ich mir einen Porsche kaufen und mal gucken, ob ich das irgendwie schaffe. Deswegen
bin ich gerne bei dem Kundenumfeld hinfahren, der ist ein Porsche-Restaurationsbetrieb
in der Porsche-Kfz-Werkstatt. Da stehen schon ab und zu ganz, ganz schicke Flitzer rum
und da kann man dann schon ab und zu mal träumen. Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, der Früher. Jetzt
kommt die geballte Technik und Fernsehpower. Momentan ist es so, das eine Telefon funktioniert
gar nicht mehr vom Vater und von uns oben teilweise nicht. Da kommt hier unten raus
oder das von unten kommt oben raus. Das ist ganz komisch kompliziert. Und jetzt mit den
neuen Funktionen hoffen wir mal, dass wir vieles einfacher machen können. Ich glaube,
das ganze System mit dem Funk-Telefonen und der Arbeitszeit, also bis wir heute fertig
sind und das alles, was er kriegt, muss er bei 3500 Euro so um den Dreh. Ja, ich habe
es jetzt auch noch nicht so oft. Das geht doch. Das ist gar nicht so teuer. Also je nach
dem, was sie dem da einbauen, ist das doch vollkommen in Ordnung. Zumal, ich weiß halt
nicht, ob das inklusive Arbeitszeit ist. Das ist nicht teuer. Wir reden ja hier nicht
von der Fritz-Box und drei Fritz-Deck-Telefonen. Was, Mann? Je nachdem, was die machen würden,
das wahrscheinlich auch reichen würde. Aber keine Ahnung. Und schauen wir mal, wie weit
wir kommen. Wir bauen jetzt die Telefonanlage in den Surfer-Schrank vom Kunden ein. Wisst
ihr, was das für ein Surfer-Schrank ist? Das erkenne ich an diesem grünen Streifen.
Das sind diese Dinger. Ich habe vergessen, wie die heißen. Das sind diese Dinger, die
du auch oftmals bei Ebay angeboten kriegst. Digitus! Digitus! Genau, die sind das. Die
meine ich, ja. Mit dem grünen Streifen. Digitus. Jaja, genau, die Dinger sind das. Keine Ahnung,
19 Zoll und dann, ja, hier. So was in der Richtung. Wie gesagt, deswegen sind die grüne
Streifen. Aber das ist nicht der Netzwerkschrank, das ist sowas hier eher. Guckt, das ist sowas.
Guckt hier mal. Jaja. Sagt doch, ich kenne die Dinger. Digitus, genau. Das sind die Dinger,
die du auch bei Ebay kriegst, wenn du direkt Sammachschrank suchst. Wollen wir mal kurz
gucken, was die da haben, falls man ein bisschen was erkennt. Aber man erkennt nicht wirklich
was. Ja, nur weil das ein Display hat, heißt das nicht wirklich was. Kennt man da irgendwas?
Erkennt ihr, was das für ein Hersteller ist? A, E, E, O, O, ne, erkenne ich nicht. Keine
Herr, keine Ahnung. Gut, das da oben ist halt ein Patch-Panel. Das da unten können
von der Farbe tatsächlich irgendein Unify-Switch oder sowas sein. Ja, ich denke auch, dass
das irgendein Unify-Switch ist. Ich denke das nur anhand hier oben dieser beleuchten
Logo-Ding. Wie heißt das Ding? A, G, F, H habe ich noch nie gehört. Telefonanlage,
ok. Was kostet sowas? Was ist das für ein Telefon? MonkaS, Alter. Sieht ja aus wie
von 1990. Ok, weiter geht's. Ich würde jetzt gerne bei dir in der Werkstatt, da hängen
doch die zwei Kabel, wo der WLAN-Sender dran ist. Da würde ich gerne einen Kabelkanal
hinmachen und eine Dose an die Wand setzen. Und wo kommt das Kabel her? Hallo, grüß
dich. Ja, grüß dich. Wir machen halt das Telefon. Aber immerhin die gute blaue Bosch-Ausrüstung,
wo muss das sein? Alter, die Bayern sind wieder am Start, Alter. Es geht irgendwie um seine
Kinder, glaube ich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Aber kein Schimmer. Wie lang?
Da hoch. Ja, das können wir schon irgendwie hier. Ja, sonst können wir aufstehen. Ja,
und die müssen untereinander verbunden sein, ob die Strecke jetzt passt. Ach, da steht's.
Ach, vier. Und dann müssen wir später in der Wohnung schauen, ob dein Fang da auch ausreichend
ist. Die guten alten, äh, na, wie heißen diese Klemmen nochmal? So Keystone-Klemmen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also die wo du quasi, ne, ne, ne, ne, das hier oben meine ich. Da
legst du das Kabel auf und dann klappst du so zusammen und das schneidet sich, äh, schneidet
sich selbst rein. Das ist huge praktisch. Ich höre Angst. Naja, sieht doch ordentlich
aus. So. Was ist denn das? Ist das irgendwie so deckt, also geht das hier zur Telefonanlage
und das ist irgendwie so ein decked access point oder sowas? Würde ich, würde ich jetzt
mal vermuten. PoE. PoE decked access point. Und das ist ein Unify. Ja, dann ist das auch
ein Unify-Switch. Es leuchtet beides, schaut fix, montiert aus. Also ich bin zufrieden.
Jetzt müssen wir halt die Telefone fertig einrichten, die Rufnummern zuweisen und dann
sind wir eigentlich schon fertig. Route 14, dann klingelt's oben in der Wohnung. Und mal
schauen, ob's sich hingeht. Ja, jetzt ist wer rangegangen, weil's grün ist. Hallo? Hallo.
Ja, passt. Ist nur ein grober Anruf, gell? Ja. Tschüss. Ja, tschüss. Tschüss. Dein
Vater kannst du anrufen. Dein Vater? Pass auf, jetzt mal schauen, ob ich das selber hinkriege.
Ja, da gibt's nen Hotkey, warte. Na was? Pass auf, warte. Und du nach 20 Sekunden nicht
hingehst, gehst in die Firma. Ach so, echt? Ja. Huge Features. Super, ja, sehr gut, gefällt
mir, ja. Passt. Ja, dann rufst du eh an, wenn nix geht oder wenn du nicht klarkommst.
War heute ein ganz entspannter Auftrag. Wir fahren jetzt weiter zum Gasthaus Franz Inselkammer,
das ist ein Neugrund. Das ist wirklich noch so richtig oldschool Turnschuhadministration.
Ich muss ja sagen, das hat auch was, ja. Also was ich jetzt persönlich nicht mag, ist so
der permanente Kundenkontakt, das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Aber das hat auch was, ja.
Also Minus-Kundenkontakt. Die in knappen 10 Tagen eröffnet. Die haben von uns schon vor
letzte Woche neue IT bekommen und schauen jetzt noch uns offene Baustellen an, machen
so eine kleine Übergabe und was wir noch so zu tun haben. Und da kommen die wichtigen
eh schon. Servus Christi. Servus. Hi Christi. Alles gut? Servus Christi. Ich bin Bayer,
oder? Immer. Letzten Tage, bevor es losgeht. Schiefgehen kann viel am ersten Tag, es braucht
ja nur einen Stromausfall geben, dann funktioniert gar nix mehr. Und deswegen, man sollte ja
für alle Sachen gewaffnet sein. Okay, ja, sollen wir in den Keller runtergehen? Ist
hier unten offen? Wir haben ganz unten die USV, das ist die Untersprechungsfreie Stromversorgung.
Man kann es als Notstromaggregat bezeichnen. Das, wenn es halt mal kurz weg ist, dass die
Maschinen anbleiben, sonst müsst ihr eine halbe Stunde warten, bis die Kasse wieder
läuft. Das Wichtige bei USVs ist, ja, das bauen die jetzt nicht ein, aber das sage
ich jetzt einfach mal dazu. Das Wichtige bei USVs ist ja auch gerade mal bei so einem
kleinen, bei so einem, was? Kleinen. Die haben ja da kein Dieselaggregat oder irgendwas
daneben, was dann anfährt und bla bla bla. Im Zweifelsfall, wenn das nach 10 Minuten
auf Low-Batterie-Stand geht, dass der Kram sich dann einfach runterfährt, das ist ja
gerade das Wichtige, dass das nicht einfach ausgeht. Dass du im Prinzip dann ein bisschen
überbrücken kannst und dann der Server und die Hardware, die da dran ist, sich ordentlich
runterfährt. Das ist der Wichtige bei USVs.